[Applause]
uh the orange Menace is back in NYC
former president Donald Trump is in
Trump Tower as he awaits his arraignment
tomorrow the whole show kicks off at 11
A.M when Trump is set to arrive at the
courthouse in downtown Manhattan he will
face a reported 34-count indictment
related to hush money payments made in
the run-up to the 2016 election Jan
sackey says giddy Democrats might want
to consider restraint
so where does that leave Democrats and
what should they be doing about the
indictment news
let me start with what I don't think you
should be doing as much as you may want
to now is not the time for a mass order
of lock em up T-shirts and mugs that's
exactly what Trump and his supporters
would do now is also not the time for
Democratic candidates to celebrate to
brag to predict the outcome of the legal
cases if you can I'd actually just put
your head down and stay out of it for
now
moderate Democrats or Republicans who've
voted to impeach Trump have doubts about
the case
it's just a very very sad day for
America very sad day especially when
people are maybe believing that this the
rule of law or Justice is not working
the way it's supposed to and it's biased
we can't have that no one should be
above the law but no one should be a
target of the law what I think is the
particular problem is it's going to lead
to all kinds of political theater
but grab your bucket and mop because the
media is wetting their pants at the mere
thought of trumpet handcuffs CNN even
had someone on a boat to capture the
moment when Trump landed in New York I
wonder if it was Don Lemon and others
are cheering it on
presidents are going to be less Lawless
and Renegade than they've been for or at
least been allowed to be for over two
Centuries with all due respect no one
should care that these people are
outraged by this indictment I'm sure he
is working on his uh lizard brain which
tells him both to fight back no matter
what and he will be fingerprinted they
will take a mug shot
um it is
just like 2016. I love how Martha how
the Press covered his arrival like it
was O.J in the white Bronco and all of
those people want him back in because he
pays their mortgage he's the he's what
gets everybody to watch the news they're
going to cover him like a burqa they
pretend that he's awful but they they
they all of those clowns need to need
him to survive
we covered it like that uh
I am one of the clowns you know it's
live it's happening he's Landing it's a
beautiful day in New York it's the big
Trump plane it's coming down and what I
noticed was that you know there was a
ton of Glee at the beginning of this
indictment process right so I went back
to my office after three o'clock I'm
getting ready for this I'm watching
different channels on now they're mad
because they're mad about people paying
attention to the motorcade they're mad
that the polls are doing well they're
mad that they raced
dollars over the course of this and they
were very grumpy I noticed over the
course of this afternoon the other thing
that I think is very interesting when
you look ahead to this case is that
you've got people saying you know the
case is going to fall apart when Michael
avenatti from prison is telling you that
Michael Cohen is not credible that is
noteworthy uh in my book he's saying wow
when they get this guy up there he's
just gonna fall apart remember you
haven't heard the other side of the case
right we've only seen what the grand
jury heard which is you know here's my
case I think it'll work here's why you
ought to just sign off on the ham
sandwich for now and let's see how it
goes
um Bob Costello has all these emails
that they say no one has ever seen so
the whole other side of this case is
about to come out and remember this
whole very similar case with John
Edwards fell apart in a huge way and he
paid he gathered a million dollars from
different donors to get money to pay his
hush money million dollars from a lot of
different people and they couldn't nail
him with that yeah but he's not Trump he
doesn't create Arrangement judge will
there be a gag order and do you think
the former president will respect it
well first thing I want to say is I
think it's a very sad day when I watched
the president
um both get on the plane and then and
and then deep plane in New York City I
couldn't help but say to myself you know
this is the president of the United
States who's being forced by a
prosecutor who said he would get him to
go to the Manhattan Criminal Court to be
booked and mugged and fingerprinted to
be brought in for an arraignment by a
judge and you know and forced to you
know say whether he pleads guilty it's
just stunning to me I mean I spent my
whole career doing this so I just think
it's a very very sad day for the country
now having said that to answer your
question I suspect the judge will
definitely issue a gag order the
question is however whether or not that
gag order in this particular case will
be constitutional because you also have
a president a former president running
for president of the United States can
you you gag a presidential candidate can
you gag someone where you know almost 50
percent of the country thinks it's a
political prosecution so everyone thinks
it's political by a guy who when he was
running said I'll get him and then you
know you you've got a judge who's got to
say to himself you know this really is
isn't constitutional I'm not sure it is
and it is everything about this
President and what he has said from day
one is that this country is not what you
think it is this is the weaponization of
the criminal justice system will they be
allowed to skirt around the 30 charges
and I believe me 30 doesn't impress me
could be one but he might be able to
just talk about the race itself they
can't stop him from doing that and I
guarantee you that if there is one there
will be an immediate appeal and that the
First Amendment Will trump a gag order
now one more thing Greg that most of the
gag orders that I I've seen in my career
have been against prosecutors for fear
that the prosecutor will somehow taint
the potential jury pool it's rare that
you get defendants who do it you know
and in this case
um there's been so much for the
prosecutor that's leaked criminal in
fact that maybe it's time to let the
defendant leak interesting you know
Harold in The Green Room you said this
indictment has turned you into an
extreme mag a Republican and you're
starting a pack with the proud boys
um I'm shocked that you're so outraged
but join the club I was on the subway
I'm trying to get here because there's
so much traffic first of all I love
being back around the table I watch
spring break two weeks that it was great
watching Everybody better be in here uh
two things
um I thought jinsaki said it best
restraint for everybody and I think the
judges answer uh substantly is exactly
right about the gag order and other
things
as well as as well as Martha but I think
the restraint should also include two
things we don't know what's in the
indictment I'm out here Mark I think
you're right we're going to get an
opportunity to hear the president defend
himself I think there's been some
defense by his lawyers I think on some
of our shows and other shows and other
other networks and the president has
obviously expressed his theory of the
case uh I think for me I'm interested in
understanding two things one what are
what are the contents of this thing this
this indictment if the indictment is
only about an elevation of misdemeanor
charges which we've all talked about
here and talked about in other shows and
judge you certainly have great
experience here if this is an elevation
of not doing this if this is an
elevation of things that were passed on
by the U.S attorney's office and passed
on by the former D.A I think you'll see
a lot of people including me saying I'm
not sure this is the right expenditure
of time uh and two this certainly
impacts the president in in a negative
way as he seeks to seek the office he
seeks the office again
but I reject and I push back on those
two and there may be even some around
the table this is not personal but I I
resent those who suggest that we don't
have a single system of justice still in
the country I'm a believer that when
juries talk you listen president Trump
May believe that he should not be
indicted we'll learn tomorrow the exact
charges and we'll hear from the
president but our system is is based on
a rule of law and there are two elements
to it one is a presumption of innocence
for anybody accused regardless of whom
you are you're what you look like where
you live or how you're educated or not
how you're educated and two facts and
evidence in a courtroom in our justice
system and we have checks and balances
because we have different levels of the
justice system an appellate court and a
supreme court uh help to make sure that
district courts or other or even a
public court doesn't act outside outside
of its boundaries so I believe the
president is innocent in any democrat or
republican who believes otherwise is not
American this is our system this is our
system of jurisprudence Pelosi he would
but approve his innocence
you should take my comment to me and I
level it in anyone with I don't care
what they look like what part of they're
in if they're my friends or not this is
the system we live in and we besmerge
our system when we don't treat people
Everyone the same way about 2 15
tomorrow we'll know what's in that
indictment and I think we will have a
much better sense of how we should be
responding and if the president is right
this thing will either be dismissed
because there's no evidence or no facts
or it will be uh we won't have a trial
because there will be a declaration by a
judge to dismiss this summarily I mean
when I say dismiss he could get this
dismissed on for substantive procedural
grounds and if he's right I wish him the
very best if not I think all of us
should be willing to let this process
unfold Harold I mean uh Jesse you heard
Harold said he's innocent thanks Harold
there's a saying in the military
different rank different spank
and there are two tears of Justice in
this country you can't tell me who the
victim is
who is the victim of this so-called
crime you can't say it as far as we know
what the indictment is and I'll
speculate is that he put the payment to
the lawyer in the wrong column
he put it in a different Ledger
so the lawyer took out a loan to pay off
stormy and Trump reimbursed the lawyer
so that went in as a legal reimbursement
no it went in his legal expense it's a
bookkeeping charge this isn't a publicly
traded company there's no victim here
this goes afterwards into the filing
cabinet and that's it and they're saying
that because he didn't put this down as
a campaign expense
then that's covering up a felony that's
bull and everybody knows it all of a
sudden we care about what Ledger you put
something into I mean what Ledger did
Hunter put the diamond he got from China
in
the Biden family took money from China
didn't pay taxes on it what about all
the missing billions and dollars from
Afghanistan gone what about who cares
there's no criminality there right but
Trump pays somebody and they're looking
at what Ledger he put that down in how
about when HSBC the bank
settled for billions in fines for money
laundering cartel cash they didn't put
anybody in prison they didn't criminally
charge any of the bankers for that or
they didn't criminally charge any of the
bankers that crashed the economy in
2008. the Manhattan D.A just sat there
and went like that but they're looking
at this this is crazy Brad is the one
that committed the felony judge knows
this right here it is a felony unlawful
grand jury disclosure how do we know
what's in this indictment how does CNN
know this because someone in the
Manhattan DA's office leaked this that's
a felony that we know is a felony unless
CNN is on the jury and we know that's
not true so we have a case shut right
there Bragg is a felon and he's trying
to make a career for himself over this
and Bragg has interfered in this
election more than Russia has or China
has combined there you go all right
you're on fire Jesse only Monday I know
all right I might have to take the rest
of the week off yes I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now